val j'ai presque vide pinocchio dit
quelque chose à les revenus la bouche
importante à boucherville
di pa pou
baboo papou j'ai un petit garçon vous
entendez qu'est ce qui t'arrive
je viens d'avoir un petit garçon je suis
papa doc et au tulle aime la façon dont
je t'ai fait moi j'aime beaucoup au
revoir mon fils au revoir j'ai amené mon
fils à l'école
pinocchio c'est pareil chez à peine fini
de te faire que tu manques de respect à
ton papa
afin d'aider à retrouver ton papa à 10
ans cadors je me présente je suis le
rodamco magnifique jetons moi je suis le
chat pineau vieux magnifique sedan
pacifique et pourquoi tu ne me raconte
pas ce qui t'es arrivé j'ai croisé deux
assassins d'abord qu'est-ce que jurent
de tout coup oh ce n'est rien tu sais
étant donné que tu me dis des mensonges
tu as le nez qui s'allonge bien vient
pinocchio souviens toi rien ne réussit
aux enfants qui désobéit 116 et
finissent par s'en mordre les doigts
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs voici pour vous
c'est quelque chose qui te plaît il va
tout laisser notre corps
tu as tout arrive t'en fais pas
je vais dans un body il s'appelle le
pays des mille jours
toi et moi a joué les magiciens
je vais devenir un petit garçon comme
ceux de mon âge